hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
we also have our second video during
this little sponsored season I like to
call it the second video is going to be
going over all of your main ganders
weapons and armor thankfully in this
account you be I have to give you a huge
round of applause last season you didn't
do this but this season he gave us every
single bit of armor and weapon that the
character has so that saves me like an
hour I was spending your three hundred
thousand steel that you give me so Big
Ups to you oh yeah we're gonna be going
over the armor first and then to the
weapons and also for the weapons if it
happens to be a star weapon I will let
you know in the bottom it'll just say
star whup and I will leave the name of
the armor set and the weapon set at the
top as well so you could be completely
up today on what weapon that
specifically is you know when to look
for it when you're in game I can't give
really specific details on what weapons
are gonna be the lower tier what ones
are gonna be high tier only you're just
gonna have to kind of guesstimate
yourself but roughly know that majority
of the weapons like usual will be in the
legendary tier so you'll probably have
about a nine out of ten chance that the
weapons you'll be seeing will be in the
legendary while some be in the gold
section yeah other than that like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I cover the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the Patrick's and the
leaks if you want to be kept up today
with everything happening within the
wall before I never miss out on an
update that first day subscribe to the
channel and also let me know in the
comments below your favorite weapon and
armor set preferably in two separate
comments so we can boost YouTube's
algorithm and maybe they'll pay me more
wink wink and with that peace out guys
have a great rest er day
you
[Music]
you